How to Buy a First-Year Wedding Anniversary Gift.
A first-year wedding anniversary is an important celebration for you and your spouse.
Use this guide to make sure the gift is as memorable as the past year.
You will need a wall map, a picture, a frame, board games, a tree, a star, a love note, and a shoebox.
Optional: pushpins.
Step one: Give them the world.
Get your spouse a wall map to hang on the wall,...
...a fun way to chronicle all your future adventures together.
Since paper is the traditional first anniversary gift, you'll be killing two birds with one stone.
Use pushpins to mark all your trips.
Step two: Blow up a funny picture of the two of you and frame it.
Every time you walk by the picture, you will both smile.
Step three: Slip a note in their pocket telling them to meet you where your first encounter took place.
The surprise and subtlety will bring you both back.
Step four: Get a collection of board games so you can play on cold or rainy days...
...or with friends and family for a game night.
Step five: Plant a tree together in your backyard.
Watch your love grow and the tree grow over the years.
Step six: Show your love is as wide as the universe by naming a star after your spouse.
You'll always be able to see it glimmering.
You can search online for a company that names stars.
Terms like "star naming" or "name your own star" will yield several results.
Step seven: Write a love note for your spouse and store it in a shoebox.
Add a new love note to the box each year.
Happy first anniversary!
Did you know? In 2008, the average age for first-time marriages in the United States was 26 for women and 28 for men.